the Joe Rogan experience you know that's
one of the things that James Wilkes from
the game-changers told me where they
were doing those regenerative farms
where they have these free ranging
chickens and this is how we're gonna get
our eggs he told me they were losing
like thousands and thousands of chickens
to Eagles he said it was so many I
forget I wish I could remember what the
number was I'll ask him but some insane
amount of death was caused by the Eagles
realizing they could just get a chicken
everyday--
just swoop in and get a chicken they're
so easy they can't even fly and they're
all in one is one pending area a big
great video I want to see that there's
got to be a video of that Jaime thank
you of course you are do you subscribe
to that Instagram nature's metal oh yeah
oh yeah we promoted that scary the wolf
with the dogs I try to tell everybody
about that yeah when the Wolves Kelly
sad
nature's metals when the best accounts
on in it all-you-can-eat buffet bald
eagles prey on farmers chickens
apparently when Eagles find out where
your chickens are your [ __ ] man cuz
coyotes at least you can put up a fence
he'd have dogs 2.2 million oh my god
farmer wins case scroll up a case
against now after losing 2.2 million
dollars worth of chickens to bald eagles
2.2 million dollars in chickens 160
thousand chickens 160 thousand chickens
to Eagle hoodie wood how crazy is that
and Eagles Eagles no you can't [ __ ] with
them that's the difference if a coyote
eats your chicken you could shoot him in
the dick
nobody cares everybody wants you to
shoot coyotes they'll go after your kids
they'll kill your cat but Eagles that's
America bro you can't shoot an eagle
[ __ ] your chicken maybe that's why maybe
he might have one I'm trying to figure
out why he won a lawsuit but maybe it's
because he couldn't protect them he's
allowed to kill Paulie Eagle yeah
because they're protected bald eagles so
I couldn't do anything about that I
guess
now our bald eagles protected because
they're very rare or is it because
they're very rare and they're our United
States bird like you know they were
trying to there's one thought at one
point time of making a puppy the United
States bird or the United States animal
it was a pitbull not a puppy it was a
pitbull yeah it was in the early the
early days of the country wow I thought
it's like recently police concern so
they're protected but they're of least
concern especially in some areas
apparently in Alaska brink of extinction
in the late 20th century it says uh-huh
that's what it is
brink effects extra extra patient extras
yeah yeah in the contiguous United
States so that means Alaska is worth a
big amount of them transferred to a list
in 1995 transferred to the list of
endangered species and was removed from
the list of endangered and threatened
wildlife in contiguous states On June 28
2007 their flying monsters that's our
bird you see the one video of the the
eagle I think it was like a not a cow
and they're just like rolling down the
hill Const oh yeah yeah go go yeah pulls
the goat off the rocks bashes his brains
in on the cat on the rocks on the way
down he rough rides them down to even
got [ __ ] up a little bit it was like
what is some what was the originals are
not even heavy those Eagles are really
light man really yeah they're like 10
pounds that's they can kill a wolf
they grab a sheep and fly with them
that's primary look how that is real
dude that's real now that's that
Photoshop you come on make it real it's
real
eagerly that's photo there's no way you
can get that picture man unless the
lighting is so different white [ __ ] come
on
just make it real why can't that be real
come on if there was a GoPro that was
that close to that
that'd be the group on you on the
Internet oh it's a rap [ __ ] the one
where he's holding a fish oh that's fake
these some of these look fake Talan
looks like a
the thing is the ones that you'll really
looks like it's not really a bald eagle
doing it golden eagle yeah yeah just
having fun yeah daddy goes carrying Andy
rock or Chris Rock what a crazy animal
to have is our number one animal I mean
it's such a emotionless ruthless beasts
like a wolf would be so much better
wolves are cool right how old they look
at you you can make a deal with them you
know they make a deal with the wolf
that's a wolf's became dogs humans made
deals with them Ryder come here man
don't eat me I'll give you some of this
I got shot at a buffalo look at all eat
bro you tell me when other [ __ ]
[ __ ] wolves are coming by I'll keep
you hooked job a buffalo there's that
photo somebody posted recently have a
woman that had a like half wolf half
timber wolf do you see that and it was
like 2 SOT 2 like it was bigger than her
oh yeah it was I look like a monster it
was even a real wolf it was just a half
wolf well a lot of those half wolves or
whatever they are man that's that's a
strong gene that wolf gene if you mix it
with a husky you know they're big man
and some Huskies are big there it is
so that's how much wolf does it's a
timber wolf is that says Colorado wolf
and Wildlife Center that's a real wolf
dude that's a wolf not the same one
anything but look how big that goddamn
thing is if that thing's imagine if that
was a rat and it was trying to kill you
well Wolf's are way scarier than rats
yeah look at the size of that thing man
it's got a collar on it though no is
that a collar looks like I call a it
looks like something's around its neck
right all right yeah
no maybe no maybe not it's just the way
it is Dean
oh my god it's licking her Oh would you
do if she just reached down starts
jerking just said video going around
they'll go for the break with that guy
has a pet tiger and it comes out of me
just like sticks his hand in its mouth
oh stop it doesn't just pet I can't
does that [ __ ] not know about
Siegfried and Roy how does he not know
about Siegfried and Roy don't do that
[Applause]